salut c'est monsieur grève aujourd'hui
vous donner les résultats pour savoir
qui a gagné qui a perdu au concours pour
les coques rhino chine
vous avez été un peu plus de 500 après
avoir participé donc je suis désolé il
ya forcément beaucoup de déçus néanmoins
cinq personnes très heureuse et j'ai
tout de suite vous donnez normand va
regarder qui seront eux puis voilà faire
un petit topo du dimanche
[Musique]
oui forcément je publie cette vidéo un
dimanche c'est le week-end on en profite
c'est un peu plus cool un peu plus cool
aujourd'hui je voulais vraiment venir
c'est déjà d'avoir été hyper nombreuses
et par nombreux va participer pour
tenter votre chance pour gagner votre
coque rhinochill s'écoule un merci à
vous d'être très très très nombreux
puits toujours plus nombreux surtout
nombreuses sur la chaîne donc là c'est
super cool
alors on avait donc en tout cinq coques
cinq coques qatar gagné la toute
première c'est la coque blanche celle là
là donc je vous avais déjà parlé c'est
louis leman louis leman qui vit à
capinghem capinghem et pas de mauvaise
prononciation donc louis celle d'aller
pour toi tu vas le recevoir très bientôt
félicitations à toi la deuxième coque
celle là qui en bois clair celle ci
c'est romain bol qui habite besançon
félicitations romain s'étend qui repart
avec cette coque
idem pour toi tu leur sera très très
prochainement chez toi la suivante celle
là en bois font des 7 doigts du noyer je
ne dis pas de bêtises
celle-là c'est adam léger qui habite à
anthony qu'il a payé félicitations à toi
adam on passe maintenant sur la coque ou
du le plus de participations c'est celle
en carbone vous a plu c'est leur carbone
c'est vrai qu'elle est sympa cccc
matisse au char qui habite à ville
villemure l'un dans la bible y aura donc
félicitations mathis selkirk l'aller
pour toi comme les autres tu vas le
recevoir très prochainement et puis le
dernier
c'est une demoiselle félicitations de
moselle où une dame je ne sais pas
désolé félicitations parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu de beaucoup participation
féminine donc là ça se sait wa houwa ou
de l'hésitation charlotte charlotte ni
cody qui habite bordeaux charlotte cette
coque quel est pour toi toi aussi tu vas
le recevoir
donc voilà félicitations à ces cinq
gagnants bravo d'avoir gagné merci
d'avoir participé
désolé pour tous les déçus en soyez
rassurée parce qu'il va y avoir d'autres
jeux qui vont arriver dans les temps à
venir donc vous aurez votre chance de
gagner à notre cadeau ultérieurement
bavaria de trucs qui vont arriver donc
rester connecté une fois de plus vous
invite à vous abonner à metz et des
jolis pouces vidéos très courtes
dimanche obligeant c'est louis cas il a
peut-être le staff et arif est bourré ce
bélier ont elles profité
donc voila merci à vous et à très
bientôt soyez sages et d'ici là pour les
sacs gucci
[Musique]